Let's talk about some different techniques for scaling, different approaches
you might take in, in a particular problem. So the
first thing you should think about is optimizing your code.
You know, if, if, if you have the option between
buying a second machine, and figuring out how to have
two machines working together on your website versus making your
code twice as fast. You know, may, maybe it's, maybe
it's easier to optimize your code. You know there are
some trade-offs here. The cost of a machine plus the maintenance
of having multiple machines. That means you need to figure out, you
know, you have to administrate those machines. Make sure they're up,
configure them, make two machines work together, all of that stuff. Versus
cost per developer. That is development time. You know, it takes,
takes some effort to optimize your code. And you know, paying people
to do that or paying yourself or you know, considering the
value of your own time for optimizing code versus adding another machine,
you know, there's a trade-off there.
And that's something you should think about.
At my company, that's something we think a lot about. You know, what does
it cost to pay a developer, and what does it cost just to add
another machine? So, kind of a big trade off there. We're not going to spend
a whole lot of time on this code optimization in this lecture. Because that's
really just learning how to program better. You know, as you get more experience
programming, you'll be able to write better and, and, and tighter code. And it,
you know as you understand how compilers work, you can start getting even more
clever and et cetera, et cetera. So, won't be covering it
in this lecture, but you'll get better at it as, as
you develop as an engineer. Another technique is caching complex operations.
We are going to spend a lot of time on this in
this [LAUGH] lecture so I'm not going to say a whole lot
about it now, but this is the name of the game. Caching.
You can upgrade your machines, which basically means, you know, you're
replacing the machines you're using now with machines that have, more memory,
more disk space, faster CPU. Now this is often a
good option. Sometimes you don't have this option at all if
you're using you know, a shared, shared platform where you don't
have control of the machines. But again, you know, some, some
you know, every couple of years machines get substantially faster,
memory gets cheaper, disk space gets cheaper. CPUs come in faster
varieties and, and greater numbers. So again, you know, just like
you're doing the tradeoff with code optimization versus adding more machines.
You have the same trade off here. Do we want to optimize the code,
or do we want to just get a faster computer? This is a perfectly fine
way to scale. In fact, it's one of the easiest ways to scale
if you have a, a system for replacing one machine with another without breaking
your website. Or maybe you might want to break your website for a
little bit while you do this. So anyway, something to keep in mind. Sometimes
it's an option, sometimes it's not. You know, It's not as fun as
optimizing your code, but it's often cheaper
and easier. And finally, another approach is
to add more machines, which we will also spending a
fair amount of time on in this lecture. You know
that optimizing code, and upgrading machines are fairly straightforward. You
know, do it when you can. Caching and dealing with multiple
machines working together in a system are more difficult but
ultimately you'll have to do them as your website gets large
enough. And that is what we'll be spending the most
time on in these lectures, how these two things fit together.
Okay, so let's move on to caching.